[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans votre
nouvelle édition dans la nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'information
locale nous sommes le mercredi 9
novembre voici les titres les politiques
s inquiète après l'élection de donald
trump à la présidentielle américaine
vous entendrez la réaction notamment de
plusieurs politiques yvelinois gauche et
droite se pose beaucoup de questions le
conseil départemental lance sa nouvelle
saison d'ateliers dédiés à la généalogie
objectifs notamment retracé l'histoire
de ses origines et dans ce journal nous
ferons également un point sur la course
des yvelinois dans le vendée globe qui
sont partis il ya trois jours des sables
d'olonne
non on ouvre donc ce journal avec ce
séisme politique aux états unis avec
l'élection de donald trump comme 45e
président des états unis une élection
surprise qui fait parler évidemment les
politiques en france jean frédéric
poisson député des yvelines est candidat
à la primaire de la droite et du centre
a par exemple félicité le nouveau
président américain pour lui je cite
après le break site c'est une nouvelle
victoire des électeurs face au système
autre réaction celle de bertrand guillon
maire socialiste de magny les hameaux de
suzanne blanc en première adjointe de
montigny le bretonneux ainsi que celle
de bruno myle yens président du modem 78
ils étaient ce matin tous les trois
présents pour l'enregistrement de la
prochaine édition de café politique avec
wilfrid ricci à découvrir à partir de ce
week-end sur notre antenne écoutez leurs
réactions
c'est leur choix on n'a pas de leçon à
donner bien au contraire on a surtout à
regarder chez nous comme ça se passe et
essayer de travailler tous sont sont
pour le bien-être des habitants est ce
que le donald trump qui arrivent et les
deux pouces en l'air etc va perdurer
déjà tout à l'heure on voyait bien que
c'était
résidents de tous les américains à la
voile a un peu mal au calme je vais me
suivre après sa position vis-à-vis de
l'europe de nous en particulier on a
bien vu qu'il comprenait le break site
parce que pourtant c'est très loin et on
est tout petit
ça ça va être très important et c'est un
peu un coup de balai ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis et ça peut avoir des
conséquences importantes où
effectivement pour les futures élections
en europe en france en allemagne
notamment il va falloir qu'on fasse
attention à tout ça et cette élection
surprise du milliardaire américain sonne
comme un avertissement pour les partis
et les candidats traditionnels européens
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle en france notamment
l'ensemble de la gauche des partis de
gauche semble mal embarquée pour espérer
pouvoir être présent au second tour
écoutez à ce propos benoît hamon député
socialiste de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines nous l'avions interrogé sur le
sujet lors de son déplacement lundi soir
dans la salle des fêtes de maurepas là
où sont accueillis actuellement des
migrants la gauche elle ne se recompose
rac a passé des moments où elle devra
clarifier son projet politique et c'est
sur ce qu'elle veut pour le pays sur ce
qu'elle veut pour les français
qu'aujourd'hui elle hésite donc on a
besoin de moments démocratiques où on
fait le monde confronte nos valeurs nos
solutions et moi je
suis je pense que on peut toujours faire
battre le coeur de la france il bat ici
à maurepas quand on accueille des
migrants il bat caen dans l'engagement
de centaines de milliers de bénévoles en
france mais il ne bat plus quand on
gouverne en tournant le dos parfois à
nos valeurs universelles et ben moi je
souhaite que ce coeur qui bat sur le
terrain il bat demain au niveau national
enfin on referme cette page politique
avec l'annoncé officielle de l'exclusion
de nicolas bauer du front national
ancien directeur de cabinet de cyrine
haute mer fn de mantes la ville s'est
notamment vu reprocher par courrier sa
participation au défilé du 1er mai aux
côtés de jean marie le pen le fn lui
reproche aussi d'avoir accusé le parti
dirigé actuellement par marine le pen je
cite de graves dérives autoritaires
arbitraire et fascisante fin de citation
dans le reste de l'actualité y à la
ville de bois d'arcy a posé la première
pierre de la maison de quartier de la
croix bonus ce nouveau bâtiment doit
favoriser la proximité au sein du
quartier il accueillera huit salles
associatives une salle polyvalente mais
également une mairie annexe coût du
projet plus d'un million et demi d'euros
l'équipement est réalisée avec grand
paris aménagements il devrait ouvrir
courant en 2018 on écoute le maire de
bois d'arcy philippe benassaya c'est un
projet qu'on avait dans notre propre
programme lorsque nous avons été élus et
notre aménagement nous a suivis sur ce
projet et c'est un projet très ambitieux
avec beaucoup de salles
pour les associations une salle de
conférence une mairie annexe au rez de
chaussée et puis surtout il répond à
notre nouveau pays et l'ue notre nouveau
paix lui qui fait attention aux
inondations et à tout ce qu'on a eu au
printemps dernier donc il y aura des
rétentions
la parcelle il y aura toit végétalisé et
il y aura beaucoup de choses qui permet
qui permettront de faire attention à ce
problème là parlons cuisine à présent
avec une initiative originale start up
de saint nom la bretèche cultive des
champignons en boîte et en sac ces mini
champignonnière sont commercialisés tels
quels aux particuliers aux restaurateurs
c'est étonnant le concept a séduit des
chefs étoilés reportage sur place de
michael et demi d'euros est alors
l'anguille
voici un sac à champignons et sa version
miniature la boîte à champignons finies
les heures passent et le dos courbé en
forêt à chercher des pleurotes celles ci
viennent à vous à l'origine de ce
produit original une start-up yvelinoise
nés en 2011 donc en fait c'est ni plus
ni moins fefac que vous voyez là mais
miniaturisés pour ça arrive dans votre
cuisine donc en fait c'est une petite
boîte que vous ouvrez vous la rosée et
quinze jours plus tard dans notre
cuisine vous avez ces pleurotes et le
succès est au rendez vous la start up
devrait connaître 100 % de croissance
cette année et atteindre un chiffre
d'affaires de 600 mille euros mais il
n'a pas inventé ce concept d'agriculture
urbaine provenant de l'hémisphère sud
depuis très longtemps dans les pays en
voie de développement on cherche à
transformer des résidus culture en
champignon pour améliorer les plaies les
enjeux notamment des tris ionel locaux
l'idée qui hack et qu'on a eu à la boîte
à champignons c2c d'appliquer ce système
qui existe au mexique ou au botswana par
exemple en afrique à la région ile de
france ici les conditions d'humidité
d'un sous bois en automne ont été
recréés dans un espace de 600 mètres
carrés on fait même croire aux
champignons que des sangliers road à
proximité quand on n'a plus comme ça sur
les sacs c'est ce qu'on appelle du
stress mécanique ster que dans la forêt
parfois vous avez des animaux comme les
sangliers par homme qui fouillait
paulson et ça ça stimule la croissance
des champignons et donc sur les sacs
comme ça où on n'a pas tout à fait à
cette grave est bon on va les stimuler
on les masses en quoi le procédé donne
une pleurotes de qualité tenant bien la
cuisson celle ci a été distingué par le
collège culinaire de france et plusieurs
chefs étoilés en raffolent on a un
produit qui ne va pas rendre dos à la
cuisson d'accord contrairement à la
grande majorité des champignons et donc
qui va rester croquants quand vous avez
goûté avec une vraie textures et ça les
chefs adore inscrits dans une démarche
écologique et solidaire la start up
vient de lever 500 mille euros de
l'argent frais qui lui permettra de
doubler sa capacité de production est de
lancer d'autres champignonnière comme
celle ci ailleurs en france
les archives départementales lancent
leur nouveau cycle de conférences sur la
généalogie le projet initié l'an passé
fait intervenir du mois novembre au mois
de mars les spécialistes sur différentes
thématiques nous avons assisté hier au
premier rendez-vous de cette série
consacrée à l'enfance reportage de
camille lambert
environ 500 enfants des traits sous x
chaque année en france c'est à dire sous
le sceau du secret l'identité de la mère
et donc anonyme pour cette première
conférence gêné à l'ab la spécialiste
myriam provence s'est penché sur les
enfants abandonnés souvent on a
l'impression que les portes de la
recherche ont fermé et le but de la
conférence c'est de donner des clés aux
auditeurs pour tenter de découvrir les
origines ou de leurs propres origines
s'ils sont eux mêmes enfants abandonnés
ou les origines de l'ancêtre né au
xviiie siècle par exemple
retracer l'histoire de ses origines
découvrir ses ancêtres une étude
présentée par les archives
départementales des yvelines depuis l'an
dernier les rendez vous gênez hallab se
propose d'initier le grand public à la
généalogie générale av c'est un cycle de
conférences dédiées la recherche
géologique
seconde saison un site qui va proposer
une thématique particulière avec un
spécialiste du domaine l'idée étant de
proposer un petit peu des ressources
inite non pas inédite mais en tout cas
peu hésité pour la recherche géologique
au delà des traditionnels état civil
recensements de population les séances
ont lieu environ un mardi par mois
jusqu'en mars 2017 prochaine enquête le
13 décembre les détectives en herbe
peuvent s'inscrire auprès des archives
départementales
en sport le vendée globe a débuté vous
le savez ce dimanche 6 novembre 29
skippers ont pris le large pour ce tour
du monde à la voile en solitaire et sans
escale depuis les sables d'olonne et
parmi s et marin de l'extrême on
retrouve trois yvelinois les versaillais
tanguy de lamotte et éric bellion et le
rambolitains louis burton retour sur les
premières heures de course avec notre
journaliste michael et minorent
3 heavy loi tente en ce moment
d'apprivoiser les vents et de dompter
les vagues sur ce vendée globe 2016 les
versaillais tanguy de lamotte éric
bellion et le rambolitains louis burton
sont partis à l'aventuré sur ce tour du
monde en solitaire et sans escale au
pointage de 15 heures ce mercredi 9
novembre imoca initiative coeur de
tanguy de lamotte et classé à la 9e
place à bord d'initiative coeur on vient
de passer la zone interdite du dst du
cap finistère et on à hisser le gennaker
avec les dauphins
bon après midi et bonne soirée à tous
c'est parti pour le tour du monde
de son côté éric bellion sur comme un
seul homme est installé à la 27ème
position pour son premier vendée globe
le skipper garde le moral
[Applaudissements]
penser
l arc en ciel
[Applaudissements]
le troisième il vit doit louis burton
qui avait dû abandonner en 2012 suite à
une collision avec un chalutier est pour
l'instant la 16e place avec son imoca
bureau vallée il vient de dépasser le
néo zélandais conrad colman à au large
du portugal cette huitième édition du
vendée globe est toujours dominé par le
fond c'est armel le cléac'h sur banque
populaire
on referme ce journal en culture avec
une oeuvre qui a 64 ans le dialogue des
carmélites écrit par georges bernanos il
donnait en ce moment au théâtre
montansier à versailles un hommage à
marcel tassencourt en signe directrice
du lieu et qui a mis en scène l'oeuvre
en 1952 reportage de mélanie poké et
nicolas landry
1789 la france connaît sa révolution le
couvent des carmélites est dévastée ces
religieux sont poursuivis le dialogue
des carmélites et mis en scène au
théâtre montansier il volonté commune du
metteur en scène et directeur du théâtre
c'est une pièce que j'ai vu aussi
beaucoup des périodes importantes de ma
vie
et c'était une façon de
rendre hommage à tout ça et de rendre
hommage aussi à
4 montant cible favorite est la pièce
pose des grandes questions sur la fois
sur le rapport à la mort sur la
spiritualité de chacun d'entre nous sur
son exigence aussi sur la politique
puisque malheureusement les révolutions
qui sont nécessaires tourne souvent mal
l'oeuvre fleuve de georges bernanos
ramener ici à 3h regroupe dix neuf
comédiens sur scène une plongée dans la
france du xviiie siècle avec un lien
fort avec l'actualité
évidemment là on a situé la majeure
partie des actions xviiie siècle le
monde la révolution ne part quelques
petits clins d'oeil à la fin on a
transporté l'époque d'une part au moment
où
l'auteur allemand qui est une femme dire
troupe von le fort est créée la nouvelle
dont s'est inspiré bernanos au moment de
la montée du fascisme en allemagne et
puis vos de nos jouets c'est
effectivement c'est tout le moment où
une religion peut être remise en cause
quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs en 1794
les seize carmélites seront guillotinés
leur destin est à découvrir jusqu'au 10
novembre
place il sort d'une fois
[Musique]
écoutez
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal merci
de nous avoir suivis prochain journal
jeudi même rendre attendant vous pouvez
revoir le reportage de nos émissions sur
notre site internet tv fil 78 points
comme bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]